hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
and as John Humphrey over here today is
Jeff bearskin Peterson's birthday yeah
happy birthday Jeff happy birthday I
only turned 17 years old next year
you'll be able to drive a claw I would
say you look good for your age but you
look a little bit older than 17 and to
have children already by here lianna's
cigarette please you gotta be way out
yes gotta be careful Jeff I hope that
you are having fun with the ladies I
just gotta say buddy you have been quite
a loyal follower of the channel you've
been one of our top patrons on patreon
since we started you have shown us
incredible support a lot of love and I
just want you to know sincerely we love
you too that joke you made about what
happened when you went to the
chiropractor and that you're a started
hurting I got that a little late haha
anyway everything wrong with the mummy
by cinema since a couple of requests for
cinemasins video react and we're cool
with cinema since we have be from the
network ooh cool that's doing reactions
to cinemasins videos I was like you know
which one I just really want to watch
The Mummy mom because I hated that movie
in certain aspects and it's Halloween
time it's Halloween time we got a lot of
horror wants to choose from why do
Friday the 13th why do you scream why do
boo to the mom let's do the super
horrible horror movie the real OG
monster sofia boutella
oh yeah
we got a lot of this jinxes expanded
universe before the first movie in the
universe even started reading let me
just whipped it's lengthy logos out
three seconds ago and then forces us to
steer them again this is clearly textual
harassment some guy puts the blood dime
into the thing and I'm supposed to be
all happy because wearing a backpack
present-day is the cop out of titles
what does it even mean when the movie
was shot forever now we have narration
so reading narration all inside five
minutes movie is intentionally trying to
trigger me you know just not even a
little bit of this information don't be
handed to the audience later yes up goes
off kills fools then we start learning
bits and pieces of all this would that
be better
sent the god of death they made a pact
you could set this Russell Crowe
narration over shots from the first
third of Noah land I probably wouldn't
be also II know it looks cool but
exactly how would quadruple seems to me
you suddenly having to process extra
visual information would at least take
some getting used to darkness ex machina
for her sins are Manette was mummified
this looks more like a speedy paper
machine Halloween costume than a true
mummification also he has now been a
ghost plaza narrating for three and a
half minutes Street I timed it so that a
parallax great I always works exactly is
going on here
target practice if so what does this guy
with the hammer doing are they really
attempting statue don't listen be a
gunfire also isn't this guy directly in
the line of fire uh uh that's gonna be
Tom Cruise for sure do who secretly wish
it was a goblin or even Robin Williams
from Fisher Gate anything to make this
movie slightly less predictable with
regard Henry does this mean here is
important to me cuz someone gonna get
shot in the head develop amnesia and
forget this movie ever happen can I
volunteer no sorry
I'm not going here we have another
overused trope where a character
repeatedly insists they're not going to
do a thing when there's no doubt in
anyone's mind they're going to
ultimately do the thing thanks for
wasting our time movie so now this
airstrike they called in arrives in like
30 seconds and does not injure or kill
either of our two heroes
yeah but surfing also brought on by the
airstrike explosion yeah how did anyone
at the studio sign off on 55 year-old
Tom Cruise playing some active special
ops field agent with a penchant for
screwing up even costume oh you know
this why do you keep sending them out if
you're gonna hunt him now so the movie
has some manufacturer this is a
reputation with Blue Star Fleet on this
how does this make any sense to send
these two down with her you just said
you don't trust them and now you're
gonna send them down with her alone I'm
so mad at you were going to give you
direct access to the very thing you came
here for this whole thing over Duff
because of an airstrike and a building
collapse but no one in volunteers seems
the least bit concerned but even more
ground around the hole might get wet
Wayne in reality the camera here is
soaking huge the entire town should have
been sucked into a sinkhole get the
lights and seven hours later up today
somehow lure all these down into the
cavern and then fed power to it as well
the lights came on the most beautiful
way to set up lights for a movie shot is
also the least practical in real life
remind me again why we set up the lights
100 feet away from the space we actually
want illuminated previously floating an
invisible handheld camera also what is
she even looking at to know what she's
shooting he absolutely has no idea how
to camera as this treasure is stolen
it's as good a time as any to bring up
the choice not to have anyone else down
here weird enough you sent down the
idiots and thieves you don't trust but
then you don't send down any security or
manpower to keep them in check I think
it might be both so what's this movie
you say that but clearly the getting out
now part of your order is going to take
45 minutes based on what we were shown
when they were lowered down by then any
bogeys will be full-on bogeying he
shoots the rope and activates the
ancient thing out of the blue after
being ordered out of there because why
even in the trailer to happen that made
any sense so he wrote this
yes very d'oeuvre for terribleness but
they created at Goonies booby trap to
bring her back up just in case of the
future they want to make movies about
giving money movie and that needs a
cheapskate goes for sudden spiders with
somewhat hilarious results do your title
maker you're going to make us really you
could do a movie in parks on a two-hour
ever need to be here and we don't want
her here yeah she shall remain not only
is this the second mummy movie to
feature a southern sandstorm it's the
second Tom Cruise movie to feature so
the Saints goes vertical from Jurassic
world on how to write go over the facts
here just stab small twice he's not
responding to your voice he looks like a
zombie he's walking towards you just end
him already what I'll see you waiting
for
oh wait those are even something so it's
a murder of Ravens also known as a real
Lewis special but what to film this
scene for the sake of authenticity a Tom
Cruise actually strapped himself into a
plane and crashed all they do is this
unnecessary bull you're slingin here
she literally met these dudes today
sure mystical resurrection blah blah
blah how was nobody been freaking out
that his body is even still intact fun
visual I guess but how would he be
unknown he was on a flight with such a
sensitive artifact material his name and
rank whatever let's just be honest you
lost me at hello you know position comic
relief zombie ghosts this is what you
have another tries using the you better
come take a look at this cliche also
just started here first mummy attack it
be more mysterious and literally
everything we've learned up till now
could easily have been given to us via
dialog flashbacks and natural story
progression does the mummy lady actually
need to kiss her victims on the lips
where she just warning I guess whoever
she moment I was actually turns into a
zombie I'm not a mummy I suppose that
makes it easier for the movie to give
our heroes some drone bad he used to
kill waiter in the finale with mummy
look did you kiss a single scratch
unbreakable remake is a lot more
multicentric then i remember the
original books you've developed a theory
out of thin air then he died movie sent
a ceremonial knife with a large order to
helped this movie is like a pubescent
boy it can't get enough of its own
expositor it ends up rubbing itself
wrong yep said Lord Hades Jehovah jay-z
they're all pissed expositional comic
relief zombie ghost also my face I'm
cursed Nick
pickle a movie Boris or brenden most of
the movie wants to curl off it up this
character feels like he should be
hanging out with preacher she's got
plans for you can't can't
even if this is true wasn't she took
show up to Nick herself and explained
why use the dead not funny friend guy as
a conduit especially when she's going to
show herself to him in the alley in the
next scene
why are rats attacking anyways is he
controlling them do you care
does it matter is it creepy okay I guess
kissing is the official kill you but
come back to life and I control you
mechanism in this bill ancient Egyptian
curses are weirdly obsessed with what is
a relatively modern romantic custom I
swear to God at this movie flashes back
to the same desert scene one more time
let me have to shove a table so far but
sarcophagus do you want even be able to
read the hieroglyphs Terry T mummy
linebacker why had she obviously
consents where these artifacts are but
somehow she didn't know that the stone
was busy instead of completing the
ritual the mummy lady goes at Virginie
one guessing pose is exactly 1.5
creature who has previously quickly and
efficiently sucked the life out of every
non crews human in her path decided to
throw her across the room instead
because reasons Tommy on skis their
lives world war see Nick takes on
without Jenny which is sexist logical
predictable and hilarious you're saying
that she brought the plane down there on
purpose yeah and with such accuracy she
must be working with the gal from hidden
figures Dumbledore been this direct with
Harry can't because they're to a minute
so we're gonna just pause real quick
through the woods I know were villains
always a quick deliberate walking with
terror because it's creepy what's more
hilarious if grabbing this stick Jenny
yelling get her Nick it's a time in my
book black ops saviors repeatedly shoot
the mummy with darts and arrows which
means there's some kind of whaling
corporation keep the evil alive for
research going down right now else
they'd be firing Hellfire missiles and
RPGs at our ass 106 market a collector
of rare monster artifacts but some on
display where they can be seen
anyone walking through oh snap
remember how Russell Crowe's in this and
it's been 8 minutes never reading the
opening yeah
shameless dark universe building
attempted shameless if he knows how
dangerous he is when he turns
why on earth we wait to be this close
before giving himself is high the Beatty
shot
guess we have to see it but power mirror
Li chains keeping this ancient god chick
can find if handcuffs were enough to
subdue her why did the Egyptians barrier
so far underground inside a stone
sarcophagi need to see the humans even
you know what
I honestly don't care a pony I love my
father with all my heart
sheet I can understand the need for a
bit of exposition to catch us up but
we've already heard yeah yeah I reach it
can't even show me at least a figure
that's ok and that's why you use
protection
always make sure your money to your is
wrap securely before burial kids well
tell you would you even have believed me
Tom Cruise's agent after she convinced
them to say yes to this film and
immediately after he read the script
met in judgment I care about you
maybe tries to get us to buy into a
relationship between two characters with
so little chemistry not even Walter
White could find it yeah dear god yes
please you language is simple only a
fictional movie character would ever
save this about the English language
because English is stuff y'all but also
you know perhaps an importantly after
one third of the movie being backstory
and one third with her trained up I'm
beginning to think this mummy movie has
very little interest in mummy thank god
this building had a museum-quality
advancement of humanoid skulls display
so that Nick would be distracted by it
so that Jekyll could surprise him with
some kind of a struggling to pretend
like a care any more on this one Chris
just FYI I'm writing a narration it's
gonna get less and less inspired as we
move forward she's talking to a spider a
spider studio is soon committed to this
dirtiness
they have to literally cram in so mr.
Hyde hey controlled spiders in your
arsenal with a couple easy incantations
and you're just now using one high-tech
fastly important door security system
has one door on a delay because you
never know when you'll need a convenient
plot point King who even when your
character is puking liquid metal I still
don't need to see characters puking and
movies goddammit movie includes cursed
book from the 1999 let me filter does
this mean those movies are in the same
world as this one this expanded universe
just got expanding her yeah good thing
she is in that door no absolutely
nothing seriously buddy has no idea how
to use this character other than some
knowledge that's position exactly what
has she done
she didn't even pull her own parachute
cord in the plane crash for pete's sake
[Music]
okay that was a badass mummy circus
Elena's right there and I take us in the
war for the fact that the rig is
needlessly complex just so it could
happen what can I say boy likes to run
in this movie with this much what
exactly does she need him for again she
just lonely
codependent honey you don't need a man
to make you whole good and you haven't
been seen in an hour I'm really thinking
you're just part of the evil chicks plan
what how did you know what she was about
to be attacked how much he remotely
close enough to save how much I'll screw
it man like I give it
lundi can't decide if it's auntie
mommy's are slow and one of the time or
zombies consistent oh she's a mommy now
too and he not trained so hard to hold
his breath for Mission Impossible rogue
nation
Tom Cruise would definitely have died
shooting this stupid underwater scene
for the stupid mummy movie wait why are
these Knights of the Dead table
disintegrating is it Nick running right
now Nick had this little control over
things why did I even watch this movie a
Jesus mummy lady why is this submission
so important to you you imprinted on him
early on presumably you do not need the
human inside him to get permission and
yet you keep asking for it throwing off
the domes runtime
[Music]
okay I'm calling a family meeting let's
count the ways this moment ruins the
last shred of hope for this bill first
other than a full surprise is there
really any reason he needs to stab
himself nothing has been mentioned about
the night giving the stabber the power
over the standing so who cares who does
the penetrate - yes absolutely no idea
so why does even think this lady friend
back to life three did you see that
night it was dull from age and curved
like bruises sternum but I needed
stabbing anything Oh what you know all
he had to do was crush the red stump the
mummy lady even said so but instead he
stabs himself with the Ruby blade that
mummy lady has been hoping to stab him
with all movie movie gives us a visual
summary of what it's been doing to us
for the last 90 minutes so attach
Virginie during this film he literally
cannot live without her like the most
force company about this movie I guess
demon Cruise is evil but does good sorry
movie you can't go both ways is the
mercury still necessary her life has
been sucked down the stone is shattered
and gently' Satan it pretty much decides
who lives or dies now anyway but what
are we even doing here bail would be
great at cinema Suez yes those I don't
know what they are don't know what
- like this flood
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
ddr man that was my song and ER for sure
i downloaded that song just because of
they pointed out so many things I really
appreciate the team in cinemasins man
because we did a full movie room and did
a spoiler review of it the main things
that were wrong with the film that
really bothered us like I pretty much
laid out here yes of all their like
attention to detail with a three eye
thing
it's cool gonna make it hard very first
trailer I was like what does that do for
you at all who like what superpower is
this it's gonna make it harder for you
to see the other things that they
pointed out that I never really noticed
you how corny be Vance he is like upset
with Tom Cruise
but yeah I'm like Tom Cruise's character
supposed to be like 20 years younger
something but we all know his hobbies
Tom Cruise in his 50s he might not look
it but we know it that's the thing about
stalkers we know he looks amazing for
his 50s well we know he's in his 50s
like he's an ogre guy history like why
do you keep hiring him why do you keep a
lot of him to work why are you still
annoyed about this yeah either accepted
you turn to me so much is happening in
the film it's I imagine for a team like
cinemasins they're like pausing the
movie and stuff and yeah I'm finding
every conceivable hole yeah yeah exactly
that is such a big hole too when his
body is found after the plane crash and
it says unknown on it I not look in the
plane no one seemed surprised at all
that his body is just perfectly intact
and a diagnosed him is dead but he looks
like great and how does he just get away
sure there have been like at least a
couple of days committed to how are you
still alive we need to run tests are you
magic like oh I'm sorry
I didn't mean to wrap you up sorry put
you in this here bag and we just thought
you were good I'm surprised you're able
to scoop breathe while you were in the
bed the intern you woke me I was so busy
hating the movie when I was watching it
I didn't even notice that they threw in
the book from the mummy from the Brendan
Fraser one you know so I did yeah is
that just a tribute or is that an actual
tie in what was a safety net yeah I feel
like at the time as a tribute but
looking at it now I'm like maybe this is
a parachute so they can go hey for the
next one
we're gonna bring brendan fraiser back
and maybe write in on nostalgia what you
don't think is really gonna happen but
you know with the wackiness that this
movie you know brings to light I don't
doubt that it's possible it might be
cool of that I might be cool with that
too
I would love to see Brendan Fraser who
is part of two much better mummy movies
and then Tom Cruise as good mummy
teaming up they gotta go save Rachel
Vice yeah I could not have hated more of
the dr. Jekyll stuff being thrown a I
didn't like any of shield being in this
movie honestly yeah I have really
couldn't even like that the note of
everything on display anyone could just
access at any point yeah why is this in
the foyer for did you and there were a
couple points in here that we touched on
in the review cuz there's so much in
this movie that is like over designed
for the sake of being cool and making a
set-piece as possible cuz that whole
thing do they chained her up in I mean
again what is the point of this weird
Cirque de Soleil Dean apparatus that
you've got her tied to that scene goes
on a long time and I'm pretty sure at a
certain point her body has to be full of
mercury you've been pumping it into her
for so long like there's her body's not
that big like it's gotta be overflowing
at some point and yeah all those skills
she's got that she only uses like once
in a while and how she selectively
chooses not to kill or decide the life
out in and a girl Jenny especially like
he should she should have just killed
her right there in that moment we seen
the first half of this movie I would
just let stuff like that go I'm like
whatever I was silly it's silly fun it's
just the last half when shield steps in
when I start getting like very annoyed
with
entirety of its like guys stop and the
Jekyll thing yeah the whole like why did
you wait to have this conversation yeah
unlike the verge of you hulking out you
like he looks like Rudd I better do this
now you've lived with this condition for
how long the whole fight with Jekyll is
is completely immediate like if you take
it out of this movie nothing changed and
it was such a good point though what
they were saying about why does she need
Tom Cruise so badly they kept repeating
it so much in the movie there was so
much repetitive exposition that's the
worst part about it was just
expositional it was repetitive yeah I
understand like okay I get it from the
first two time it is even now that's
been a few months since we've seen it
I'm like I kind of forgot already
why she needed Tom Curren as part of me
wants to relearn why and part of me does
not anxious I feel like I'm just gonna
be more upset when I remind myself yeah
yeah you know the weird thing is about
this movie after it was done this is one
of those rumors I just couldn't stand so
much I had to like watch interviews with
everyone and then I even saw a like a
half hour panel they did it at some time
in New York wasn't a comic-con it was
just some panel in the or they're
playing it somewhere and I saw multiple
interviews with Tom Cruise and in the
director too when you hear them talk I
know you're contractually obligated to
not talk ill of a movie you know a lot
of trouble when you do that especially
for a big studio film like this so
you're contractually obligated to not
speak ill of a movie but when they talk
about it you're like I think they made
something really seem like they it's a
good movie you know when Christian Bale
promoting Terminator Salvation you're
like this guy knows his movies crap you
know fool the talk the actors going
about about character development and
everything it's it's it's important but
it's far less important in a movie like
this you know what do people want to see
people want to see the terminators they
want to see them fighting the
terminators they want to see that that's
the exciting stuff that's what's a novel
about this
good you can see the enemies here like
everyone involved seems like they really
thought they were doing a good movie
maybe they went back and corrected those
interviews and posts yeah maybe they did
some age correction technology and just
decided to change the whole dialogue to
you alright guys well thanks cinemasins
for putting that awesome list together
you guys are fantastic at what you do
guys reminded me of how much I didn't
enjoy about this movie yeah John and I
will turn off the camera and then bash
the mummy more our own time like we'd
like to do it's been a while since I've
seen one of these videos and I really
enjoyed the the end sequence of just a
little reference alright alright guys
well happy birthday once more to you
Jeff bearskin Peterson wanted to give
you the birthday shout-out you guys can
subscribe to the real rejects subscribe
to cinemasins
click that notification bell in the real
Rejects good notified every time one of
our videos is out and you could follow
us on social media links in the
description box good day